-Your son is coming up on
his second birthday, right?
-Second birthday.
Same age as your guy.
-Yep, same as mine.
And you --
I know you have to do
a lot of press
when you're promoting shows,
press like this,
which must be exhausting
with a 2-year-old.
-Yes. So, like, the big
difference between
when we started the show
and six years later,
we do very similar
kind of press things.
So, six years ago,
we would've been, you know,
meeting between
each press event
and drinking massive
amounts of wine,
and, like, making out
in a bathroom somewhere.
-Great.
-Okay.
-That's awesome.
[ Laughter ]
-This year,
the exact same schedule,
exact same press event, we --
I'm not joking --
asked our driver, in between,
to not only not go to have
drinks and make-out places,
we said, "Can you pull over?
And can we take a nap
in the car?"
I was like,
"What has our life come to?"
A nap? In our fancy clothes
just like this in the car.
-Nothing would be more
terrifying than walking by
and seeing the cast of
"The Americans"
asleep in the back of a car.
I'd be like, "Oh, no!
They're dead!"
-"They're dead."
I know.
-Spoiler alert --
they die in a car.
[ Laughter ]
They fully die in a car.
-They looked nice,
but they're dead.
-Matthew is Welsh.
-He's Welsh.
-And is he speaking Welsh
with the baby?
-He is. So, he speaks --
Welsh is his first language
and speaks exclusively in Welsh.
So we, as a family,
all learn colors, numbers...
yeah, and that's how we do.
-How is --
Is a baby speaking Welsh cute?
-Very.
-Okay.
'Cause it's a pretty --
It's, like, an intense language.
-It's an intense language.
-Yeah.
-He does a very good job,
and it is -- it's amazing.
So he's sort of tri-lingual,
because we also have
someone in our house
who speaks Spanish.
So we do like chww --
-How do you say, like,
"mother" and "father" in Welsh?
-Well, he just says
mama and dada.
-Oh, well,
so he's not crushing it?
[ Laughter ]
-Not yet.
Well, he's got plenty of time.
But I do want to ask, like,
did you know it before
when you had --
before you had a 2-year-old?
Was there any reason
for you guys to speak Welsh
up until that point?
-I spoke a little bit.
I mean his family,
when he calls home,
when he speaks to his sister
on the phone, he speaks Welsh.
So now I can say, "What are
we doing at 4:00 on Tuesday?"
You know, and he'll go,
"Oh, she's learning too much."
You know what I mean?
-Oh!
And now, though --
Like, you guys can now --
You kind of have
your own spy language now.
-Which is kind of amazing.
Yeah.
-So, like, if you guys were out,
like, walking the streets,
you could do a little Welsh?
-You could do a little Welsh,
and you could talk some serious
[bleep] about people.
-Wow. Is Welsh
a good language for that?
They have a lot of [bleep] talk?
[ Both laugh ]
-Are you -- So, are you
bittersweet about it?
It must feel like
such an accomplishment
to finish this show
that was so well received
and beloved
by the people who watched it.
-It is.
I mean, personally,
it was such a great job.
It was a really,
really great job,
and, obviously,
I had some huge life changes
connected with it,
but at the same time,
we're kind of --
we're not out of it yet.
-Yeah.
-I'm still celebrating
the fact that, you know,
I'm out, I'm free.
-Right.
-Which is so --
I feel like I just
got out of school,
and I'm going for, like,
lunch by myself,
which feels amazing!
Which may seem
really boring to you,
but lunch by myself
feels amazing
and not with 200, you know,
crew members.
-Yeah.
Also you get to dress in, like,
decade-appropriate clothing.
[ Laughter ]
-This is also true.
-Yeah.
Not a lot of wig wearing or,
you know, 1980s eye shadow.
-Well, I cannot congratulate you
and everyone involved
in the show enough.
And it's always just
such a delight to see you.
Please do come back again.
-Okay, fine!.
-It wasn't your last time here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Keri Russell, everybody!